كان ميخائيل جورباتشوف
من أكثر الشخصيات شهرة في السياسة في القرن العشرين ،
وكانت محاولاته لإصلاح الاتحاد
السوفيتي ودوره في إنهاء الحرب الباردة ،
من أكثر الشخصيات نفوذاً أيضًا
عندما درس غورباتشوف شابًا.  القانون في
جامعة ولاية موسكو ، التقى هناك
وتزوج من زميلته الطالبة راسا
تيتارينكو ، وواصل العمل في
الحزب الشيوعي في نهاية المطاف في سن 54
ليصبح أمينًا عامًا للحزب
زعيمًا للاتحاد السوفياتي
، وكان هذا الدور هو الذي انفصل فيه غورباتشوف
وزوجته  إن القالب الذي
يمثله بسبب طبيعته الكاريزمية المنتهية ولايته يثير
ملابسها الأنيقة
والأناقة التي لم يسمع بها من قبل لدور
السيدة الأولى في الاتحاد السوفيتي ،
لكن الأمة الشيوعية الواسعة التي حكموا
كانت على شفا أزمة وسط
نقص في المواد الغذائية والسلع الاستهلاكية في
السوفييت.  كان الاقتصاد الموجه يتجه نحو
التوقف ، كما كان هناك قلق من
الاستجابة البطيئة على ما يبدو من جانب السلطات السوفيتية
تجاه الأمن النووي.  حاول أستر في
تشيرنوبيل
إصلاح الأمور مع ما أسماه
إصلاحات البيريسترويكا والجليسنوست التي
كانت ستحدث ثورة في النظام السوفيتي ،
وبدأت هذه الإصلاحات وكانت نجومي المرشدين
هي الحرية والديمقراطية دون
إراقة دماء حتى يتوقف الناس عن
أن يُسمع صوتهم بقيادة راعي يفعلون ذلك.
أصبحوا مواطنين ،
كانت هناك الثورة الثانية في العلاقات
مع الغرب
وجهًا لوجه مع رئيس الولايات المتحدة رونالد
ريغان غورباتشوف قدم اقتراحًا مذهلاً
لإزالة جميع
الصواريخ النووية التي تحتفظ بها القوتان العظميان
، كانت بداية نهاية
الحرب الباردة قريبًا.
السقوط وبعد الانقلاب الفاشل من قبل المتشددين في
موسكو ، تم حل الاتحاد السوفيتي نفسه
واستقال غورباتشوف ،
بموجب هذا أوقفت أنشطتي
في منصب رئيس الاتحاد السوفياتي
في عام 1999 ، فقد حب حياته
زوجته لمدة 46 عامًا.
اللوكيميا
ولكن لم يكن هناك حب ضائع بين العديد من
الروس وغورباتشوف لكثير من أبناء وطنه ،
فقد كان دائمًا الرجل
الذي  أغمضت الإمبراطورية السوفيتية العظيمة على
الانهيار وتعريض الملايين
للمشقة والإذلال حتى عبر غورباتشوف نفسه
عن أسفه ، لكن في الغرب كان يتم
تبجيله والاحتفاء به كرجل دولة عظيم
فائز بجائزة السلام النبيلة الذي
لعب دورًا حاسمًا في إنهاء
الحرب الباردة سلميًا لنزع فتيل أكثر
مواجهة خطيرة
في القرن العشرين
لك